I told you that time and college where
this dude he was just kind of like just
big and pudgy and he was a masseuse and
my back always hurt
I didn't wrestle because my back hurts
how I was always looking for somebody to
[ __ ] so he gets in there and he
starts getting my taint and I go what's
going on man he goes this is where all
your nerves are and that area is where
oh I didn't know he goes you haven't
listened he goes this area is really
where your nerve center and I was dumb
enough and you're gonna have to be like
I guess I'm 19 I don't know 18 you look
like you yeah I'm like [ __ ] and I was
like you like it old man dude he was
like I got older you know junior or
something and I was like maybe a senior
I was like oh you this is not no no I he
wasn't on the team he was just to do to
my dorm who was a masseuse and I'm like
he had me turn over a naked and I'm
[ __ ] no I had a towel ah but the
[ __ ] is now reaching in and
doing this so I go I'm like [ __ ] man I
go well it's not that comfortable he
goes well you will get comfortable and
then I swear to God he goes he goes
altum Utley what you want to do is be
able to put your fingers in the anus and
massage the nerve the cluster of nerves
that really relaxes your body and I go
okay man well I'm gonna just turn over I
just got to get my lower back not that
area he did not get off my taint and and
finally he got to my lower back Monstars
your lardo real hard no I [ __ ] of
course didn't but I was like there was
the most uncomfortable [ __ ] I've ever
had in my life now I find out later on I
go I'm I go now did he eat my buddy Dan
goes yup he did that [ __ ] to me he did
that [ __ ] to me but I also know a bunch
of guys I got their [ __ ] sucked on this
[ __ ] right now I go what I mean cuz he
was tight with the dude oh wow and he
talked about two dudes who couldn't bend
more much I wonder was from the Middle
East
get macho as [ __ ] in his dick thug and
and he he blew both of them and I go I
go I never said I said I go I don't even
want to say his name out loud but let's
just say his name is Hassan I go Hassan
and he goes well he's Arab so you know
we I was like what do you mean these
Arab that doesn't think that's not gay
it was this so funny yeah he's
his game he was a gay he was a gay man
he'll your school was a gay man what he
did is he was a gay man he goes I'm
gonna figure out a way to suck danseuse
I'm a masseuse and I'm gonna come up
with a new technique and there's gonna
be a couple guys that are gonna bite and
they bid and they bet and they bit put
your finger in my
oh there's it's in my butt now my dong
well you're not changing the story it's
a blur brawl was young I'm not in a
court of law
man I never told you I would I tell you
they got molested by the camp can well
that was a long time ago I'm pet some
[ __ ] happen to your booty but you know
no not my booty sorry sir
well I'm just saying that general area
nine ever
what was that dead Joanie Duff David off
on a true story
guy said I'll give you my baseball cards
because he goes look I took a light
molestation when I was a kid I'll be
honest with you guys showed me some
baseball cards and let me see it I
showed it to him you know maybe touch
that I remember and he goes either way a
lot of people call that Mel station I
call it a good deal exposed Brian taught
racism yeah start it dude please so I'm
outside Rob we see Brian he's coming up
and we you know we do the regular bro
handshake half hug bang and at one point
there's a black lady two black ladies
and holding a black baby like a couple
of feet away from me just in the lobby
outside and Brian goes hey that's just
situation and I go I'm just amazed that
she was so mad dead serious dead serious
he thought that was my two holes and a
baby that's right we just kept talking
about that's crazy
would you assume that well I made it
even work so I went into another story
about another black guy that I know who
has girlfriends and then cut to the
holiday Christmas but then cut to my
money and wah oh so we got the Asians of
the [ __ ] in seconds white privilege
man that is a [ __ ] I want to
apologize
Arizona apologize I got to pologize I
mean I'm I talked to the agents first of
all no
than being deaf no I'm gonna read I'm
gonna redeem myself cat in Vietnamese a
way to tell me what how I would say cat
the white boys here to pick you up cat
tongue me gentleman ah good my B ugh
yeah copy that [ __ ] hold on
alright I let's see who has the best
memory do it one more time cat yeah
tongue me Jung a bundle Tommy done an M
huh
dang major money yeah well good maybe
I'll do my birria good my big Luke why
good now [ __ ] that's something else
I didn't say for rebei racism just
spills out of you bro
so the racist podcast no no listen now I
want to know that same thing but cat
this [ __ ] here to pick you up cat hung
Medien
what aw look might be up now let me say
what I think you just said dad this
[ __ ] here to pick you up
cat this black guy over there is not how
you say [ __ ] Vietnamese we don't have
that word it's just made early so my
evenings American and the gang is a
color black so it's like that American
black guy is here right is there any
emphasis you could put on the word to
get that made that hard are on no I
guess the clothes thing is if we call
you something before like if I called
you like that [ __ ] over there is like
gone way you know that [ __ ] over there
oh there's this you saw this boys hi guy
accidentally kicked the referee as
they're trying to break him up and knock
him down
oh right in the nose it's gotta hurt
like a [ __ ] alright this
announcer just a little over oh yeah
kick right in the nose it's not like it
ripped his head off
ah good for him he stepped right into
that kick that's gotta hurt
what else yet you know kick to the old
chops yup kick to the nose I'll drop you
quick unfortunately that net guy he was
arrested again well that's not me this
time I think they're trying to get him
really cuz yeah well he had like him he
give them real bad history of crime chin
all right well it was marijuana
possession his neck out of it cut to his
neck in trouble come on Brian seriously
and he was trying to elude you know what
happens next
don't be thick thick-headed will you
stick your neck out on the line alright
yeah the guys out there essentially
emotionally naked alright so got neck as
a mother you know you heard this new
thing necrophilia alright what's next
what so you got arrested again for just
being a complete [ __ ] crazy changing
lanes spired license up my pyramid a
human pyramid but speaking the same guy
do you get arrested for imitating a
thumb I've seen people get arrested for
imitating a stingray what else you got
it tells a stingray I've seen tattoos he
looks like a human arrow he looks like a
stingray yeah
and yeah so this guy's also there's an
MMA organization that wants him to fight
either in MMA or boxing oh good luck
choking them Island
good luck choking him out though I mean
going getting he does fight no no he
doesn't know background so kind of like
you know because he's big in the news
right now that Ramona I'm Jesus Christ
what an embarrassment embarrassing [ __ ]
come fight know he hasn't made some of
the best choices in life in the past so
maybe something like this would be good
be a good step in the right direction
well I disagree I feel like to get the
CEO when you watch TV wasn't Eddie
Murphy's brother anymore I mean he was
such as Omer if he said it took forever
to get out of it is also you know he
wasn't doing stand-up for the lungs you
start off as Eddie Murphy's bodyguard
right I've heard some stones is secure
yeah yeah Charlie was always an
intimidating-looking dude Oh like like I
was [ __ ] a guy and he came not
necessarily big but you could tell in
his face if he didn't smile he did db5
you up yeah you know like Eddie looked a
little softer yeah I always said it
almost looked like they tried to
recreate Eddie in a lab and went oh [ __ ]
we [ __ ] up Charlie Murphy yeah yeah
yeah Charlie just came off the horse
look yeah like don't here's I like I
don't play a lot especially back when he
did see before yes cuz that's when I
first saw me too I was like that
[ __ ] look like he'd tell you
sternum and he was the bad guy in yeah
yeah hmm yeah but actually I was at the
Beverly Center and I'm riding up an
escalator and Charlie's coming down and
he looks at me he just goes you funny
[ __ ] man and it was but it felt
like yeah you know I'm saying yeah funny
[ __ ] man yeah and he said it
kind just like that tend to be yeah man
yeah that's a good feeling that's pretty
cool he was the most welcoming person
though I've ever worked with really ever
a good man that's a real bummer man I
must be it's a really good no human
Rogan tour together yeah Rogan told me
he tells the best stories ever ever
forever forever senator you guys the
best storytellers Charlie Murphy no when
you see my back ripple and I pull myself
up like a champ like a champ
thirty times fast while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a get it's a gift it's a gift